one of the most important things to
realize about reading is that it is a
fairly new invention in human history a
couple of millennia old only after the
invention of the alphabet and for a long
time reading was really just a kind of
adjunct to oral communication because a
you know most of human history we just
conversed and exchange information
through speech and so one of the
fascinating things about early writing
on slates on papyrus even on early
handwritten books is for instance there
were no spaces between the words people
just wrote wrote in continuous script
and that's because that's the way we
hear speech you know when somebody's
talking to us they're not putting pauses
carefully putting pauses between words
it all flows together the problem with
that though is it's very hard to read a
lot of your mental energy goes to
figuring out where does one word end and
the next begin and as a result all
reading was done in the in the early
years out loud there was no such thing
as silent reading because you had to
read out loud in order to figure out you
know where is a word ending and whereas
whereas a word beginning and it was only
in around the Year 800 or 900 that we
saw the introduction of word spaces and
suddenly reading became in a sense
either in suddenly you had the the
arrival of silent reading which changed
the act of reading from just
transcription of speech to something
that every individual did on their own
and suddenly you had this whole ideal of
the silent solitary reader who was
improving their mind expanding the
horizons and so forth and when Gutenberg
invented the printing press around 1450
what that served to do is take this new
very attentive very deep form of reading
which had been limited to just you know
monasteries and universities and by
making books much cheaper and much more
available spread that way of reading out
too much much larger mass audience and
so we saw for the last 500 years or so
one of the one of the central facts of
culture was deep solitary reading the
immersion of ourselves in books in long
articles and so forth
with the arrival with the transfer now
of texts more and more on two screens we
see I think a new and in some ways a
more primitive way of reading in order
to take in information off a screen when
you're also being bombarded by all sorts
of other information and when there's
links in the text where you have to
think even just for a fraction of second
you know do I click on this link or not
suddenly reading again becomes a more
cognitively intensive act the way it was
back when there were no spaces between
words and as a result I think we begin
to lose the ability to read it in the
deepest most interpretive ways because
we're not kind of calming our mind and
just focusing on the argument or the
story